>> So okay, so let's think about General sum games, so not zero sum any
more. But we're not, you know, restricted,
it could be any kind of relationship between
the two players. And so the first thing we need to do is realize well,
well we can't really do minimax here
any more. Right, because that doesn't make sense.
>> Right. That only works with zero-sum games.
>> Well it's only, yeah. That's, well, it sort of assumes that the
other player's trying to minimize my reward and that's not the, that's not the
concept of the Nash equilibrium. We'd like to
do something analogous and find a Nash equilibrium in
this general sum setting. So what, what operator do
you think we would need in this context here?
>> Nash equilibrium?
>> Yeah, so that would be a very reasonable thing to
do, is instead of computing mini max, we actually compute of the
two matrix game, right, using Q1 and Q2, compute the Nash
equilibrium of that and propagate that value back. It's a well defined
notion, right, that we can summarize the value of these two pay of matrices
with with a pair of numbers which are the values of the Nash equilibrium.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Alright, so so good. So we can
do the same thing in the Q learning setting.
Substitute in a Nash equilibrium. And we can call
that algorithm Nash-Q, which is, appears in the literature.
>> Nice.
>> Oh minimax Q by the way is something
that I wrote about. Nash-Q is a different algorithm.
>> So it's not as cool, is what you're saying.
>> Well, let's let's see how it goes. So this is
now an algorithm, you can actually, well, this set of equations it's
not exactly clear what it means, but we can think about turning
that into value iteration, right? By turning this into an assignment statement.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, what happens? Well, value iteration
doesn't work.
>> No.
>> So, yeah, so if you, you repeat
this over and over again, things, weird things
can happen, it doesn't, it doesn't really converge,
it doesn't really solve this system of equations necessarily.
>> Hm.
>> And unfortunately the, the reasoning here is even
harder in the case of Nash-Q because in the case
of Nash-Q, it's really trying to solve this system of
equations using something like value iteration, but with extra stocasticity.
And so it also suffers the same problem.
It doesn't necessarily converge. There's not really a
unique solution to Q star because you can
have different Nash equilibria that have different values.
>> Right.
>> So there isn't really much hope of converting to
the answer because there isn't the answer. The the policies
can not be computed independently, right, so Nash equilibrium is
really defined as a joint behavior, and so we can't
just have two different players computing Q values. Even if we could compute the
Q values. It wouldn't necessarily tell us what to do with the policies, because
if you take two different policies that are both half of a Nash equilibrium,
two halves of a Nash equilibrium do
not necessarily make a whole Nash equilibrium.
>> Right.
>> because they could be incompatible. So, you know, so far so good, right?
>> Yeah, I can't wait to see what happens next.
>> The update is not efficient unless
P equals PPAD, which is to say, computing a Nash
equilibrium is not a polynomial time operation as far as
we know. It is as hard as any problem in
a class that's known as PPAD. And this is actually a
relatively recent result, in the, in the last five, ten
years. And this class is believed to be as hard
as, as NP. So, possibly harder. So it doesn't really,
doesn't really give us any leverage to, computational leverage to kind of
break it down in this way. So that's unfortunate. And
finally, the last little hope of, well, maybe we can define
this kind of learning scenario using Q functions the same way
we've been doing, Q functions are not sufficient to specify the
policy. That is to say, even if I could do all
these other things, efficiently compute a solution of, you know, build
the Q values, make them so that they're compatible with each
other. And now I just tell you, here's your Q function.
Now decide how to behave, you can't. It's, there's not enough information.
>> You're depressing me, Michael.
>> Yes, so this is kind of sad. We go to the general sum
case, which in some sense is the only case that matters' because zero sum
never really happens. And what we discover is that we lose all, seemingly lose
all of the leverage that we have in the context of Q type algorithms.
>> Mm, mm, mm.
>> And that's where we'll stop.
>> Oh. So we're going to end on a high note.
>> No, maybe we should say something before we depart.
>> Let's do that. Come up with something positive to say.
>> Okay.